[Music]
all right some very very uh troubling
news just happened this past week
i'm just kidding i don't know i don't
even know what it is that's the end of
the video
that is one of those start like opposite
news where you like start off like it's
sad but then it's probably i probably
should do it's like jk's new we should
always cheer when he goes all right we
got some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happened
let's go anthony that's probably like
the two seconds of happiness we're gonna
get before he crushes it because
you know steve green does that he goes
all right guys there's gonna be sad one
then it's like some guy got a usb cord
in his dick
and that is pretty sad this isn't one of
those right this is making it way worse
all right maybe we should redo it
interrupt us man yeah why don't you let
us see you guys the show you know do a
different article please
hey this is jk news
not just seriously you know what it's
just important because we were talking
just before this like it's it's
important for the jk platform to also
bring asian awareness stuff to light and
and that's why i just felt like we
should talk about oh it's not another
one of those asian hate things again god
damn there's too many going on right now
so a woman was followed and fatally
stabbed in her chinatown apartment in
new york oh [ __ ] man chinatown
what's going on in chinatown right now
where there's all this asian hate and
then there's no more chinese triads or
like there used to be hella asian gangs
like oh yeah
i think they are
i think they reformed themselves and
then the green dragons like lawyers and
stuff now we got to bring back asian
gangs bro i mean what was better
this is real like this is honestly
speaking right because we grew up in
that gang era like right here
uh because i remember in chinatown like
some um
one of those shopkeepers were getting
harassed right from some you know guys
that look like gang members and whatever
um
and then you saw these two old chinese
dudes roll up and then that this one guy
pulled up his shirt he had two [ __ ]
guns right here and then the kids looked
at it and they just ran and i was like
holy [ __ ] that's a mafia stuff right
and i'm like this was happening
you know all the way up until the early
2000s where uh there were a lot of
tough dudes just like
keeping this peace i guess you know you
didn't see any violence in chinatown but
right now it's like where are they are
they all in jail
and which one's better is it better to
have those guys there exploiting the
neighborhood but at least old ladies are
safe
uh like they're because they're still
extorting their own people you know what
i mean like the gangs aren't angels yeah
but is that better or is or is it you
know now that the world is a little bit
safer but then you it's not because you
got these guys coming in beating up all
old asians and [ __ ] this lady right here
is not even old she her name's christina
younoli she's actually a creative
producer at a digital music platform
splice yeah and she's uh
and this was a 25 year old man who was
arrested in killing and
yeah pretty much she was 35 that's what
it is so it's young people just damn
yeah stabbed to death inside her lower
manhattan apartment early sunday by a
man who had followed her from the street
and into her building wow the women who
police identify as christina yunilee was
the latest person of asian descent
injured or killed in a string of random
attacks in new york city many of them
committed by people who had severe
mental illness that's the other side of
that right that's the side that like
unfortunately we don't really hear
enough about is a lot of these asian
attacks are from people that are just
severely mentally ill so so when they
say like asian hate right like maybe
some of them are racially motivated but
not all of them like you're saying
there's just a lot of people that need
help that are just nuts that are biting
people punching people for no reason
yeah no i think i think i think it's
both right i think it's both i think a
lot of them are racially motivated but i
also see i've seen the videos that i've
seen on the asian hay stuff you get
they end up being mentally ill right did
you play devil's advocate how come it's
not like uh a string of attacks on the
other races too i don't i don't know i
don't think it's just like a real
category
media i think it's media yeah it's muted
so wait they're not attacking white
people and all that stuff it's mainly
asians that are being uh attacked and
then so obviously asians in response to
it are saying that oh my god there's
been a 361 increase in asian related
crimes and stuff since the coronavirus
so misinformation about like it being
from china and blah blah has spurred
some sort of like you know insecurity or
hate but at the same time when i'm
seeing these articles if anything from
like the writer's point of view or from
the devil's advocate point of view
you're always talking about like oh it's
mental illness mental illness but if you
look at the patterns and stuff and again
i don't want to be saying something
unpopular but also most of the time it's
also all black people but like they
never talk about that you know what i'm
saying so i think you're just seeing
kind of like a melting pot of a lot of
[ __ ] up stuff at the same time for
sure for sure and on the one hand you
can be like maybe this is a pattern
whether it be asian people whether it be
mentally ill people whether it be
because the pattern is what i'm seeing
um on all the videos of the attacks it's
usually like uh it is it is a lot it is
for some reason it is a lot of black
and asian and is it because they're you
know so it's it's obviously not middle
class or wealthy black people or like
whatever right but it's just the down
and out people so is it is it because
the community is doing it or is it
because it just so happens that they're
uh a part of that
poor
minority group that is in new york and
it just so happens that they're black so
for example right we're in an asian
neighborhood so there's a lot of asians
here so obviously the burglaries are
gonna be a bunch of asians that are
committing the crime right so in all
these neighborhoods oakland new york
there's a lot of poor black people right
so then it's not happening in georgia
it's not happening in tennessee so is it
that's that's what i'm confused of is it
like is it is is it just because like
they're super poor or like they're just
on drugs or like i don't think it's a
race thing i think it's like some kind
of issue is going on that we don't
understand yet yeah i think it's like
what anthony said it's a it's a
combination of all these things together
that create this
kind of like
in a way like a weird phenomenon
and i think for most people what they
deduce is just from not
from the outside and what the media
headlines are it's easy to say
it's just
race on race crime yeah that's that's
the bear level but then as you dig into
it then you start to see oh maybe
there's a little men on this aspect
maybe there's a some aspect from you
know racism about the coronavirus maybe
there's an aspect about just like what
you said joe about the the poor
communities and just being in a
community together and it's just like
that's the easiest target unfortunately
but i think a lot of the times too some
of these people that commit these crimes
they are looking for easy targets and i
think the combination is like if you're
like just watching the like the asian
news and you're not really looking into
it too much you are going to just think
oh black people hate asians and that's
all you're going to come up with but
yeah you're not willing to see the fact
that like in the demographic of homeless
like or just dismally low-income crazy
people
there are actually a lot of black people
in that 100 in that exact demographic
and those attacks i think even in the
mind of a [ __ ] mentally ill just far
gone person even that guy in his crazy
ass mind still sees asians as a perfect
ideal victim 100 i i mean if if you tell
a crazy person regardless of what race
right yeah if you go
this [ __ ] came from china and the reason
why
all all of us are getting sick and we
have to be in quarantine is because of
chinese um you know a lot of americans
also don't know the difference between
asian american and chinese from china
they call us all chinese yeah so
so even cyclists is that [ __ ] so
if a normal so if a normal american
right a racist baby
is four year old normal as in like if an
average american who who can actually
communicate they're not mentally ill if
they don't even know the difference
between an asian american and a china
from china you know chinese from china
then what's gonna happen when a mentally
ill person on drugs sees an asian person
walking down the street they're going to
be like you're the [ __ ] problem he's
probably paranoid schizophrenic already
yeah so that's the thing you already had
hella conspiracy theories before this
yeah so it's an ideal paranoid
schizophrenic response to be like oh
this is the enemy i have to kill them
dude
you see like you see it a lot like yeah
you really see these patterns i saw this
one video this uh this black dude on a
subway just like
having these delusions about like how
this asian dude is like in his face
right and he's just like this old
chinese dude and he's just on the he see
i even did it right now he's probably
not even chinese who knows what he is he
could be korean bro but in my eyes and
my expert opinion you're [ __ ] i think
he was trying to [ __ ] race i think
but he's just standing there and he he's
trying his best to like
just ignore the guy but this guy's
getting in his face and just creating
that delusion that that talk of like you
know you're the enemy blah blah blah so
i i think it is a weird combination of
just all these different variables
because that's what we have to think
about it's all nuanced right like if we
if we read a headline we we have to kind
of look into it a little bit more and
yeah i think the harmful thing is
thinking it's any one of those things
isolated exactly it's not gonna [ __ ] all
of it up like dude it is a perfect storm
of all these like different [ __ ]
factors yeah and then the media doesn't
help either because
looking it up the thing is what sucks is
it's not as simple as like black people
hate asian people
or any it's so [ __ ] stupid to think
of it that way no it's just like um it's
more like
there's mentally like ill people that
that are just taking out their anger on
what they believe should be happening
but at the same time they're not even
operating on logic and this is not to
excuse the thing or whatever this
phenomenon exists but then it also we
can't talk about it because if you talk
about it then it's like oh you just so
racist against black people and i'm like
no that's not even the case because i
don't even see them as
black people you know what i mean i see
them as like like if you saw asian
crackhead that's not an that's not
normal asian people yeah that's a
crackhead that's a [ __ ] crap
so when christmas crackhead yeah you see
a black dude like stabbing up an old
asian grandma you don't go oh black
people added again
it's like community
that's not the [ __ ] yeah that's a
black community yeah that's so stupid
right but then that's what turned i
think that's what happens because you
see it over and over and over and you
think like oh [ __ ] what happened here
you know unfortunately it's a more
interesting headline what's gonna grabs
people's attention more than asian hate
crime you know or or just or putting
that certain narrative out there when
people are scrolling and they see that
they're gonna look into it and click
that that is the irony though because
if most of the victims are asians
uh and for that same reason too where
it's like you know maybe asians are just
the easiest victims or whatever in some
sort of weird subconscious understanding
that everybody happens to have
then it is an asian oh yeah yeah you
know for sure for sure so it's it's just
i think it's just all shitty regardless
but the fact that it keeps on happening
it is painting a really really unique
problem in today's generation that needs
to be talked about even if the answer is
complex
do they have an intent from this guy is
this guy just well here's the thing this
guy you know because there's
surveillance video that shows him like
following her into her place um and you
know she was found dead like a what was
it a bathtub oh my god for real when i
when i did a little bit of a deep dive
into this it's um so
guess there's a uptick in like
you know these crazy violent you know
crimes right but
you know statistically it's all over in
major cities
petty crime as well as just all sorts of
crime is happening so even in asian
dominant places like hawaii right and so
one of the issues i think is because
from these cities uh they want to change
the way that they police and so
prosecutors aren't prosecuting so let's
say
and and repetitive offenders are being
let loose especially in california and
if you see the rap sheet criminal
justice reforms yeah if you see the rap
sheet of these guys i guarantee you that
they have a [ __ ] ton of assistance i
had like seven assaults right see there
you go this guy mr nash has a history of
misdemeanor arrest court records show
including an incident in september of
grand street station near the building
where the killing occurred when a 62
year old man told the police that mr
nash had punched him in the face after
after he swiped his metro card for
another passenger like so my question is
right
why is the state failing
where why aren't these guys locked up
and why are they allowed to be let on
the loose because if you hear every
single one of these stories of you know
this crazy dude [ __ ] up this asian
lady whatever right
it's never their first time
they've been violent before to other
people to people of their own community
whatever right so it's not their first
time committing a crime and all of their
victims aren't asian you know they
[ __ ] up an old black dude or whatever
right so like if you see the rap sheet
my whole thing is why is there an agenda
right now for the prosecutors to let
loose everybody and to not prosecute
this is
the one this is the number one thing
that's just mind-blowing it's so bad to
the point that some of the people they
pick up today they just got caught for
the same crime 48 to 72 hours ago for
real yeah like some guy stealing a car
gta and he just got he just stole the
car three days ago got processed when
you do an actual gta yeah and so what
blows my mind to is that so this is
happening in oakland new york la and out
of all places honolulu so even really
wow yeah cause so i have you know
friends in different police departments
in different cities right and then so
i'm tying all these dots together and
i'm like what's going on in these uh
predominantly
left-wing cities now i don't get like
too political but there is a political
agenda because if all the prosecutors
are
like left-leaning or they're on that
spectrum of the you know team
and they don't believe in prosecuting
right now
and also there's the whole thief on the
police and all this stuff going on so
what's happening all over is our friend
from uh our our cop friend here from la
and and in honolulu they both say cops
are doing their jobs they're catching
bad guys right and so like one incident
in honolulu's there's a guy that's
constantly groping women and he's
[ __ ] out there molesting all these
women
and so they catch him
but then the prosecutor doesn't want to
prosecute because it's not a severe
crime so what he ends up doing is he
goes back out and he touches girls and
he basically gets crazier and crazier up
until the point where they're like we
gotta do something about this dude and
then it got worse because he feels it
like untouchable yeah he is empowered
now right so when we're seeing these
things where like
you know all these people are getting
stabbed and beat it's because they're
allowed to do it so they're positively
reinforced they're not being punished so
maybe one one time it'll start with a
punch in the face the next it's a
[ __ ] stabbing and it just keeps going
and going and going so my i play i put
the blame on the prosecutors in our
justice system oh 100 who don't want to
um incarcerate and rehabilitate in the
right way because i'm like this is the
reason why it's happening and i think
it's a stupid reason to be like oh it's
just because black people hate us i
think that's the stupidest thing that's
a cop hour yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you